.
ALL RIGHT HANNITY I'LL TAKE OFF
OR YOU LEFT OFF.
I'M LAURA INGRAHAM THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
THANKS MUCH FOR BEING WITH US.
GRUESOME NEWSOM COMES AFTER FOX
PRIME TIME HOST INCLUDING YOURS
TRULY.
I WILL RESPOND SO STAY TUNE FOR
THAT.
BUT FIRST, WAVE ELECTIONS THAT
IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT ANGLE.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: NOW IT'S NOT JUST
THE ARRIVAL OF CRIST FALL
WEATHER WHETHER THERE'S OTHER
CHANGE IN THE AIR AS WELL.
I COULD TELL US A LOT ABOUT HOW
THINGS WILL PLAY OUT HERE IN
NOVEMBER MIDTERMS.
>> THE EXIT POLLS SAYS THEY ARE
HARD RIGHT TO SCORE ANOTHER
STUNNING SUCCESS AT THE BALLOT
BOX.
>> YOU COULD THINK THAT IN
SWEDEN A PARTY WITH RIGHT WING
NEOFASCIST ROOTS WOULD NOW BE
DOMINANT IN PARLIAMENT.
IN FRANCE, THE RIGHT-WING
PARTIES HAVE SUCH A STRONG
SHOWING.
>> Laura: IT TURNS OUT THE
REGULAR WORKING PEOPLE ARE
GROWING INCREASINGLY FED UP WITH
ASTONISHMENT POLITICIANS NOT
JUST HERE BUT ABROAD AS WELL.
ITALY'S NEW PRIME MINISTER IS IN
FIRST AS SHE IS THE FIRST WOMAN
EVER TO BE ELECTED
PRIME MINISTER THERE.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT OUR PRESS IS
USUALLY OVER THE MOON WHEN THE
FIRST IS A LIBERAL WOMAN.
OR A MINORITY OR A.
BUT NOT IN THIS CASE.
>> ITALY HAS ELECTED ITS FIRST
PRIME MINISTER NOTE THIS THOUGH,
SHE IS SAID TO LEAD THE MOST FAR
RIGHT GOVERNMENT IN THE COUNTRY
SINCE MUSSOLINI.
>> SINCE THE FIRST TIME SINCE
BENITO MUSSOLINI THEY WILL HAVE
A FAR RIGHT GOVERNMENT.
>> WITH ROOTS IN THE FAR
FASCISM.
>> THEY ARE COMFORTABLE WITH
SOME OF THE ITALIAN FASCISM LIKE
THIS MOTTO.
GOD, FATHERLAND, AND FAMILY.
>> Laura: THREE THINGS THAT
THE MEDIA DESPISE GOD, FATHER'S
OF NUCLEAR FAMILY.
I MEAN THIS IS JUST RIDICULOUS.
IF ANY GROUP TODAY COMES CLOSE
TO MUSSOLINI AND HIS BRUTAL AND
FOR MISUSE OF BIG BUSINESS AND
BIG GOVERNMENT TOGETHER IT'S THE
MODERN LEFT BUT NICE TRY KIDS.
OF COURSE THE REASON THIS VERSE
IN ITALY DOES NOT COUNT IS
BECAUSE SHE IS EMPLOYED THE
GLOBALIST GAME SHE REFUSES TO.
SHE HAS BEEN BOUGHT OFF AND THAT
SHE CALLS OUT THE FAILURES OF
THE MAJORITY PARTIES AND REFUSES
TO SUBMIT TO THEIR LOCAL CRUSADE
AGAINST NATIONAL IDENTITY,
NATIONAL CULTURE.
THIS IS HER BACK IN 2019.
>> WISE THE FAMILY AN ENEMY?
WHY IS THE FAMILY SO
FRIGHTENING?
BECAUSE DEFINES US, BECAUSE IT
DEFINES OUR IDENTITY.
AS THOUGH THEY TAKE A NATIONAL
IDENTITY.
THE ATTACK RELIGIOUS IDENTITY.
THE ATTACK GENDER IDENTITY.
THE ATTACK FAMILY IDENTITY.
I CANNOT DO FOR MYSELF AS
ITALIAN I'M A CHRISTIAN, WOMAN,
MOTHER, I MUST BE CITIZEN EXIT.
IT GENDER ACTS, PARENT ONE,
PARENT TOO.
I MUST BE A NUMBER.
BECAUSE WHEN I'M ONLY A NUMBER
ON IT LONGER HAVE IDENTITY THAT
I WILL BE THE PERFECT AT THE
MERCY OF FINANCIAL SPECULATORS.
THE PERFECT CONSUMER.
>> Laura: I SUGGEST YOU WATCH
YOUR ENTIRE SPEECH IT IS
FANTASTIC.
ON A POSTED TONIGHT
LauraIngraham.com.
NOW THE FACT IS EUROPE IS FACING
A LARGELY SELF-INFLICTED ENERGY
CRISIS THIS WINTER IT'S CAN BE
HORRIFIC.
ALTHOUGH IT'S EASIER JUST TO
BLAME VLADIMIR PUTIN OF COURSE.
IN EUROPE HAS STRUGGLED WITH A
STAMPEDE OF MIGRANTS FROM THE
NORTHEAST IN AFRICA.
THIS WAS FORCED ON THEM BY THE
E.U. YEARS AGO ESPECIALLY IN
SEAT SWEDEN THE BURDEN ON SOCIAL
SERVICES SCHOOLS, AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS BEEN A
NIGHTMARISH.
NO CRIMES UNLIKE ANYTHING THE
POLICE HAVE REPORTED BEFORE IN
SWEDEN INCLUDING BOMBINGS HAVE
BECOME COMMONPLACE.
>> THESE HUMILIATION CRIMES THEY
HAVE INCREASED THE LAST FEW
YEARS ALSO CALLED DOMINATION
VIOLENCE WERE A YOUNG PERSON CAN
BE AT GUNPOINT, TORTURE FOR
HOURS, JUST BECAUSE HE IS A
SWEDE AND THERE IS SUCH
RESENTMENT AMONG SOME PEOPLE.
>> Laura: THIS IS OVERWHELMED
THE ONCE VERY CLASSIC COUNTRY.
BUT HOW CAN ANYBODY BLAME THE PY
VOTING TO STOP THIS MADNESS?
CANNOT DO SO WOULD BE INSANE.
SOMETHING OF A NATIONAL DEATH
WISH.
AND AS THE PASSAGE OF BRECK SICK
AS A BELLWETHER FOR 2016 FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
COULD THE RECENT POPULACE
VICTORIES ACROSS EUROPE SHOWED
DIFFERENT G.O.P. MIDTERM
SUCCESSES?
THE GRIM FACES ON THE FAUX
INTELLECTUAL CLASS SEEMS TO
INDICATE YES.
>> THE VICTORY OF A PARTY THAT
HAS ITS ROOTS IN ITALIAN FASCISM
[LAUGHS]
PLANET SIMPER IS CONCERNED AND
EVERYBODY.
IT ACCOMPANIES AS AS YOU SAID
THIS MOVE IN EUROPE THAT THERE
IS THIS POPULACE RAGE THAT IS
SWEEPING ACROSS EUROPE THAT
SWEPT ACROSS AMERICA.
IN 26 ELECTION.
>> Laura: THERE IS NO
CURIOSITY AND NO EFFORT
WHATSOEVER I WILL REPORTING
HERE.
SUPPOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE SERENELY
TUCKED AWAY ON THEIR SAVE
ENCLAVES OF THEIR OWN THAT
SHOULD BE DISMISSED THESE TWO
ELEMENTS OUT OF HAND.
THEIR ANALYSIS OF WIKIPEDIA
SEARCH.
IT IS LAZY.
THE SAME DYNAMIC IS PLAYING OUT
THERE WHILE THE POPULACE
CANDIDATES IN AMERICA FIRST
POLICIES THE WORKAROUND FROM OR
ROUNDLY RIDICULED AND RESISTED
THAT REALLY ANY SUBSTANTIVE
ARGUMENT BY THE SAME PEOPLE.
THERE IS LITERALLY NOTHING WHEN
YOU LOOK AT IT, NOTHING THAT THE
BIPARTISAN ESTABLISHMENT AND
ESPECIALLY NOW THE DEMOCRATS.
NOTHING THAT THEY HAVE TOUCHED
THAT THEY HAVEN'T SCREWED UP.
THE ENERGY SECTOR, NOW ARE
FACING THE SKY RECORD ENERGY
PRICES JUST IN TIME FOR THE
GREAT FREEZE HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND IN EUROPE.
OF COURSE FOREIGN AFFAIRS, THEY
THROUGH RUSSIA INTO THE ARMS OF
CHINA WITH THEIR IDIOTIC
HANDLING OF UKRAINE.
AND OF COURSE THE CLIMATE CHANGE
OBSESSION, CHILEANS BORROWED,
CHILEANS PRINTED AND EVENTUALLY
WILL BE SPENT ON GREEN MARXIST
POLICIES THAT WOULD JUST ROB US
OF OUR FREEDOM AND OUR
PROSPERITY AND WE ARE ALL
WATCHING THE FINANCIAL MARKETS
DOWN, DOWN, DOWN ALL OF THIS IS
DRAGGING US INTO A GLOBAL
RECESSION.
>> President Biden: THE PAST
FEW YEARS HAVE STRAINED AND
TESTED OUR TRANSATLANTIC
RELATIONSHIP.
THE UNITED STATES IS DETERMINED,
DETERMINED TO REENGAGE WITH
EUROPE.
TO CONSULT WITH YOU, EARN BACK
OUR POSITION OF TRUST AND
LEADERSHIP.
>> Laura: THEY LOVE IS AMERICA
FIRST POLICIES AND THEY WERE
THRILLED TO HEAR THOSE KINDS OF
WORDS FROM JOE BIDEN WHEN HE
WON.
HOW ARE THINGS FEELING NOW BOYS
AND GIRLS?
THE THING ABOUT RADICAL
GLOBALIST MEANS NEVER HAVING TO
SAY YOU'RE SORRY OR FRANKLY
NEVER HAVING TO CHANGE HER MIND
ABOUT ANYTHING.
I PERFORM POLICY DISASTERS AT
THE AFGHANISTAN PULLOUT.
OUR DOMESTIC POLICY WITH THE
COVERT SCHOOL CLOSURES.
>> STILL FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS EVEN IN YOUR
HOME STATE HANDLED THE PANDEMIC?
>> I THINK WE WERE UNDER
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES AT THAT
POINT WERE PEOPLE REALLY WERE
STRUGGLING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
WAS THE BEST WEIGHT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR KIDS, FAMILIES,
CHILDREN WERE SAFE.
NUMBER PEOPLE WERE DYING.
>> Laura: I DIDN'T RECOGNIZE
HER.
SHE WAS HE TO BE IN WASHINGTON
STATE.
SO LOOK, LISTENING TO HER SHE
CAN'T OFFEND HER PAYMASTER THE
TEACHERS UNIONS.
EVEN WHEN THE TEACHERS UNIONS IT
TRULY SATISFIES THEIR CHILDREN'S
LEARNING FOR THEIR OWN
CONVENIENCE AND THEIR OWN POWER.
SO THERE'S ONLY SO LONG EVEN THE
BLUEST OF BLUE ESTATES LIKE
WASHINGTON STATE, OREGON, EVEN
NEW ENGLAND.
THERE WERE LAW-ABIDING
AMERICANS.
TO TOLERATE GHOULISH SCENES LIKE
THIS.
♪ ♪
[BLEEP] >> Laura: LOOK WHEN
YOU AREN'T SAFE, YOU AREN'T
FREE.
AGAIN THE PARTY IN POWER DOESN'T
BELIEVE IT BEARS ANY
RESPONSIBILITY.
SO HERE IS REALITY.
THE PRESS CAN TRY TO KEEP
SPINNING AWAY THIS POPULACE
AWAKENING HAPPENING HERE IN
EUROPE.
IT IS NOT CAN HELP THEM.
THE ASSESSMENT HERE LIKE OVER
THERE, IT'S OUT OF IDEAS, THEY
CAN'T FIX THE ECONOMY, THE CAN'T
STOP CRIME.
YOU CAN'T SEE THE NUCLEAR DANGER
IN UKRAINE.
THEY CAN'T OR WON'T STOP THE
BORDER INVASION.
AND AMERICANS DON'T LIKE THAT.
OVER TIME IT WILL TURN TO
OFFICIALS WHO CAN ACTUALLY
DELIVER POSITIVE RESULTS.
THE FUTURE I THINK BELONGS TO
PLACES LIKE TEXAS, FLORIDA,
VIRGINIA, TENNESSEE, IOWA.
IN OTHER PARTS OF AMERICA STATE
GOVERNMENTS ARE ACTUALLY WORKING
TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF THE
PEOPLE.
WHAT A NOVEL CONCEPT?
SO THE QUESTION THAT EVERY
AMERICAN HAS TO ASK IS THIS.
DO YOU WANT TO BE ON THE WINNING
SIDE, OR DO YOU WANT TO GO DOWN
WITH THE SOURPUSS IS LIKE LIZ
CHENEY AND NANCY PELOSI?
YOU WANT TO FEEL SAFE AGAIN?
WOULD YOU WANT TO WORRY ABOUT
CRIME?
DO I MAKE MONEY?
OR DO YOU WANT TO WATCH YOUR
401(K) DISAPPEAR?
THERE IS A WAY OF COMING AND IT
IS NEV